depuis un an c'est ici que cette jeune
fille de 25 ans poursuit ses études de
langues
après un master chez elle en algérie
elle a choisi de venir à besançon et
très vite a été informé par une
association qu une résidence de
personnes âgées proposer un logement à
une étudiante
l'idée c'est d'avoir un logement gratuit
voilà et travaillé neuf heures par
semaine un t2 tout confort pour un
étudiant callum c c'est une opportunité
[Musique]
nous habite donc ici un appartement
identique à celui que loue les résidents
voilà j'ai un talent que vous pouvez le
voir et c'est une chambre et la salle de
bains et puis une terrasse là où je
prends mon petit déjeuner se dire un
bouquin ici puis voilà en échange sa
seule obligation c'est de passer du
temps avec les personnes âgées à
domicile ou dans les parties communes
c'est plutôt une relation de voisinage
anti baas tient à faire une petite
partie de pétanque y fait beau les viens
on va on va jouer je joue pas trop aux
cartes mais on joue du rummikub
les triomino assez des choses qu'ils
aiment bien rigolo des jeux de la
lecture ou simplement du temps passé à
bavarder tout est prétexte à les chances
pour jouer pour pour tenir compagnie
pour faire toutes importantes tout un
sens exact bout et par le biais d'une
étudiante on a peut-être d'autres choses
à partager
l'étudiant peut raconter ces journées
l'étudiant peut partager un repas avec
nos résidents et cela apporte une valeur
ajoutée plutôt que de rester forcément
entre seniors et en une année de
présence nour a déjà créé de vrais liens
comme ici avec charles ancien
instituteur de 93 ans qui lui a dédié un
poème et je lui ai vraiment été ému les
meubles et si vous l'avez 3 yves labbé
en mémoire hélas cette beauté qui vient
d'inde loire avec des yeux des bennes
qu'on ne peut qu'admirer et qui vous
considèrent et vous font chavirer et 17e
lumière comme boulot dénommé et à la
plus grande satisfaction du poète et des
autres le bail de la jeune étudiante
soit bien tout juste d'être reconduit
pour un an des montants soient prestant
ciné conte mêlant sa présence demain
autant qu'hier